la sombra el confinamiento planea sobre
beijing la capital cuenta con 41 casos
desde que el brote fuera descubierto el
viernes es una cifra ridícula en una
ciudad de más de 21 millones de
habitantes pero que aquí basta para que
salten todas las alarmas muchos
pequineses corren esta mañana a
aprovisionarse y ya por la tarde
faltaban muchos productos en los
supermercados no hay pánico pero si hay
preocupación y cautela especialmente en
chaoyang el distrito céntrico de la
capital que suma la mayoría de los casos
sus tres millones y medio de habitantes
pasarán por tres rondas de test durante
esta semana y las autoridades les han
pedido que limiten sus movimientos nadie
olvida aquí que schengen la macro ciudad
del sur fue sellada con apenas una
sesentena de casos y que gracias a eso
consiguió controlar el brote en apenas
una semana el caso contrario es sean hai
que tomó medidas muy tibias al principio
y que sólo ordenó el confinamiento
masivo cuando sumaba miles de contagios
diarios el resultado es que shanghai ya
va por su quinta semana de encierro y
que hoy informaba de 51 muertes es la
cifra más alta desde que se iniciara el
brote y es seguro que pekín utilizará la
receta de shenyang y no la de shanghai